hello freak [ __ ] he's hilarious
that's what happens if you have a half a
billion dollars give a [ __ ] in the
beginning which is why he's perfect for
the UFC I said I picture he went right
before he right after he did the whole
deal where they sold and everything he
was on like ESPN he was on some show and
he was just slouched over looked like it
like a pile of crap and I took a picture
of it I sent it to him I said bro why
don't you sit like you have four hundred
million dollars anything or at least
invest in some some [ __ ] Fitness [ __ ]
or something I said a picture just all
slumped over like this
I think he's super stressed I think he's
better now I think that time was like a
crazy assed time what could you imagine
you're about to get involved in a four
billion dollar deal and then how about
afterwards all the [ __ ] starts falling
apart
Rhonda get smirked connor decides to go
to boxing you know the sports falling
off in a lot of the pay-per-view buys
John Jones test positive again like so
much I mean he was on his way to being a
next gigantic superstar right I mean if
you take away his his time off right the
time off where he get busted before we
had to take a whole year off because the
dick pills all this different stuff the
time off from the car accident take all
the time off and John keeps winning and
you got a goddamn gigantic superstar the
likes of like anybody that's ever been
in the UFC maybe even right up there
with Connor means you don't know even
even I mean all the negative stuff
that's happened in John Jones people are
still booing DC and cheered him I mean Z
has some great PR going it's that I
don't think it's that at all I don't
think it's I don't think they have the
brain I don't think anybody alive has
the brains to organize public response I
think public people tweet to P they love
John because what John is first of all
he's a ruthless killer inside the
Octagon and then he [ __ ] up but he's
still a bad [ __ ] like he runs it
when he was getting booed and everything
and then he took the time off and then
by the time he came back people were
back on his side it's like you know he
has food when was he getting booed never
he's getting booed like before he got
suspend
the time before really yeah
when tested positive for Coke I can't
remember I'm getting booted and if but
if he was it was nothing like DC DC wins
fights and gets booed it's crazy you
know I mean he beats Rumble he gets
booed people get mad at him they got mad
at him when he beat Rumble member what
are you bullying the guy just [ __ ]
choked out Rumble Johnson how are you
yeah for the second time
how are you booing I don't get it but
you can't the public yeah you can't get
fickle it was decided they decide who
they love and they decide who they hate
I'll tell you what though Jon speech
after he beat DC was beautiful yeah it
was good it was it was great but it was
followed up by what steroid toast that's
why it's so sad
that's I'm look I'm hoping just like
everybody else there's some sort of a
[ __ ] yeah and then we figure out
something happened something was wrong
well I really fought it too much I don't
really know that's not good no that's
not good well he tested positive for
something that only shows up in urine
test and so they did him a urine test
after the weigh-ins he tested positive
for this stuff and then they did a blood
test and you know his campus saying oh
it's not in the blood test well they
don't test for it in the blood type
that's why did you load your intestine a
blood test this is two different tests
it's like bball like the main t-ball
team to rant about or sometimes it's um
it's a weird substance that not a lot of
people take so apparently Chael Sonnen
was talking about it that if he's taken
that like this is some real old-school
steroid it took a short-acting short
short half-life steroid it's sad it's
sad I I just don't think I mean what's
what are you proving that's my whole
thing well he must have felt like he
needed some sort of an edge if he took
it if he took it or or the real problem
is or was he taking stuff the whole time
did he get involved those powerlifter
dudes and start taking [ __ ] because
remember he's got [ __ ] super dude he
was massive
yeah I mean he literally was going to
heavy weight he looks huge yeah I mean I
don't want to speculate oh really yeah I
know but
[Applause]
[Music]